tipping has become a burden 25 50 75
tips for a takeout order or Starbucks
coffee and don't even get me started on
food delivery apps if you're ordering
something small be prepared to leave a
tip that's worth more than your order
itself it's not just restaurants where
you'll be tipping either nowadays
tipping is commonplace at barber shops
car washes Ubers plumbers and basically
any other service that you can think of
which doesn't really make sense and
inflation has only made this worse now
I'm not trying to suggest that these
people shouldn't be paid a fair wage but
rather that it should be reflected in
The Upfront price this wouldn't not only
make it easier for customers to gauge
just how much they're spending for a
service but it also makes the income of
the service worker much more stable